welcome back to new rockstars this is
the big question the podcast that gives
you
too much information about kill counts
but uh not from horror films because you
know we're
we're triggered little soy boys but
instead the kills of marvel super
villains
sequels come on come on kill me i'm here
coming i'm eric voss with me is tommy
bechdold how you doing hello
i'm doing great everybody all i've got
to say is person woman
man camera television
everybody's got it going on up here this
is a perfect brain
ask me again in 15 minutes and i'll say
person woman man camera television and
that's the sign of a genius
believe me and it's gonna look even more
impressive that you can recall this
because we shoot these a week and a half
early so two weeks
from now no one's gonna remember what
that refers to let's go ahead and try
that again great to be here everyone
ignore what i just said the rule says
play it as it lies
tommy a couple weeks ago uh before this
you were um
the host of the episode that went into
the kill counts of the avengers and all
the marvel heroes yeah very interesting
one
uh some people had some uh criticisms
for the way we counted the chitauri
fleet in the avengers
but now it's our chance for redemption
so our big question for you today tommy
you're gonna go through the other side
of it which marvel villain is the
deadliest
besides thanos because we know thanos is
the deadliest but like how
more deadly is he than the others and
how do the others rank we will we'll get
to we'll get to thanos because we're
going to pay respects to him
yeah this is a this is a very compelling
and deadly list first thing i'm going to
do is go through a little lightning
round of some of the villains that have
lesser kill counts and just give you
their stats so that you know
everybody kind of we give a frame of
reference for who we're dealing with
starting with quentin beck aka mysterio
who has one kill that is himself and
we're not even sure if it's real
jake gyllenhaal killing my my will to
uh resist his unbelievable charms as
well so that's two deaths yeah he was
willing to kill more
uh and it looks like there might have
been some people maybe caught under
rubble but we didn't
see any these spiderman movies are
pretty light by comparison
right and let's remember these are these
are we are we're we're theorizing these
are mcu
deaths okay these are these are desks
that we can kind of deduce
from the films okay so don't at me next
we have adrian toomes aka vulture
has one kill his employee not looking
good
for uh the better business bureau uh he
killed jackson by accident
i guess logan marshall green had to die
because he looks too much like tom hardy
that's a good point that's a very good
point so jackson was the original
shocker he took two in the shirt then
went one in the dirt
darren cross aka yellow jacket killed
three people
frank a pilot oh but you know we we
gotta pause and uh press that f for
frank
because that guy had one of the most
horrific deaths the way he really
wiped up off that bathroom floor and
flush was pretty awful to see you want
to talk about how the spider-man movies
are kind of light
that was dark and like if you sat and
thought about that moment for a little
bit and like
put any person that you've ever known or
cared about in frank's shoes and
imagined
that level of like what if they were
just erased that way it could be a long
night for you i would stay awake for
hours thinking about that don't do that
guys don't do that
hey stay back stay back here
over here uncle ben
all right so next we have ivan vonko
whiplash with nine
plus nine ish kills we have inmates
cops guards i mean the entire ecosystem
of a prison ivan is taken out
next we have zemo with at least 14. we
have a hydro colonel kind of a
plus you know minus category broussard
the raging engine shield agents and
other winter soldiers that he's taken
out
oh yeah the other the other five he he
killed them all and then
uh that plot point started to take off
and it was immediately discarded well
there's just so many balls in the air uh
in these movies that you can't always
finish everything so then we've got
aldridge killian with
18 kills uh he's got uh extra missed
patience
and innocence caught in his blasts oh
yeah each one that blew up caught a a
few in that blast radio so
yeah he's responsible for all those i
would say next we've got kaiselius with
20 plus kills librarian drums sorcerers
in london
and hong kong sanctums he just went ham
yeah we didn't see those happen
we only saw the end of those like the
the destruction at the end but you gotta
imagine
he he took out a you know about a dozen
and a half sounds about right
then we've got young rug yonrog
25 at least scrolls just and that's got
to be at least because like as we talked
about with carol danvers last
uh or a couple weeks ago like there was
years where
that squad of commandos was taking out
scrolls so
that's the ones we know about these are
the on-screen or at least referred to
on-screen deaths that we can kind of uh
put up there so
apologies for not being higher up on the
list but uh that's all we know for
now then we've got coming in to close
out our lightning round
obadiah stain aka the iron monger with
31
kills including terrorists which is
always tough to mourn the loss of a
terrorist
rasa and several motorists the motorists
are a little more unfortunate than the
terrorists
not that you can ever really weigh human
life but if i had to choose
between a motorist and a terrorist i'd
probably go with the motorist and that's
just
you know you could say he didn't
necessarily pull that trigger to
it was like his guys but like right he's
responsible for all those deaths he's
the one who who ordered the kill
so uh while he may not be in the best
physical condition compared to the other
ones we just mentioned
i mean you know uh zemo killed way more
probably in his lifetime
but just on screen all those bodies
piled up as a result of open eye sting
so that brings us to our real
meat and potatoes list beans greens
potatoes tomatoes
the true killers the true villainous
killers here
last time we did the good guys and we
put them in categories based on horror
movie villains and then their actual
kills
i thought for this week in honor of the
class of 2020 we would do yearbook
superlatives for these murderous
goons so uh the first award the first
superlative is gonna go to
most changed you know most changed from
freshman year to senior year and that's
uh emil blonsky aka abomination because
what a glow up
what a glow up for abomination dozens of
harlem residents murdered
dozens of enemies from his days as a
special ops commando and he drank a dog
in brazil which is not a murder
but it's really sad it hurt that one
probably hurt more than any other
takedown of that movie
all right next we have most secretive
most secretive this is the shy person in
your class
you don't want this superlative yeah
this but you know i'm not talking about
shy like dangerous i'm talking like shy
like what's going on with this guy
who is he and that would be johan
schmidt aka red skull
not exactly what he seems with 60 plus
kills
allied soldiers fellow nazis again
tough to mourn that one in captain
america one
also if we attribute all those people
killed under hydra to him that's
probably thousands more but we can't
really quantify that so
we just have you know the the allied
soldiers and nazis that he killed
and plus we we owe the winner soldiers
killings can
could be abstractly recredited to him
you know if you trace the red strings
yeah you know so next we have uh
i'm gonna go best eyes remember best
eyes as a category
uh that's gonna be uh we're gonna give
that to mel keith from thor the dark
world with 91 plus kills
uh including asgardian soldiers
sacrificing his own soldiers which is he
did yeah
common theme with these really you know
bad bad guys is they will just
throw a few of their own soldiers in on
the pile with really nothing uh
no guilt or anything he fought bore in a
past war
and could have killed thousands more and
that rhymes and that's nice and people
like when i run so that's
why you're done well you did a thor
martha right there that's right
um and yeah i think that's the thing
with malachi he's one of the lamer more
forgettable villains but because he
fought for
thousands of years and then he went to
hibernation but like leading up to that
we saw him on the battlefield there and
in that battle he did kill a good number
of people and probably killed countless
more
so it's not just he was just like a one
and done person who's alive for a couple
days and then moved on
he was around for a while so yeah he
sucks but he did kill a good number of
people
damn those eyes okay and next we're
gonna go with class poet this is some
this is an intellectual someone who
moves you with the written word and
their
and their skills as an orator and that
goes to our friend ultron with 186
plus kills uh including pietro maximoff
sad got an avenger got a feeling he
might be back
uh struck her and just a lot of
sakovians for sure
yeah was there something like 177
sokovians yes uh
and you could say those are all pretty
much his fault or one of his drones
faults
and then he also killed jarvis who kind
of came back his vision right so that's
i know and that to me is the biggest
loss here we killed jarvis and replaced
him with this
i'm gonna mention this every chance i
get i know you vision heads
love vision hate me saying this but
jarvis was freaking great and we haven't
had a truly great replacement for jarvis
instead we got
this stupid red idiot that we have to
watch now also like jarvis
had somehow way more of a personality
than vision yeah
like how is that possible it was really
teasing like you teased tony in the
movies a little ostentatious don't you
think
what was i thinking you're usually so
discreet vision is just like
his mind is somewhere else he's got like
the personal skills of dr manhattan the
way like he can't relate to people
anymore
moving on uh to our next this one is
class clown this guy
is you know he's unreliable he's a wild
card
he's good for a laugh and that would be
our friend yondu with at least
200 about 201 we think dozens okay
of cicarians his own again
talk about another person willing to
sacrifice a few of his own and himself
he did
he he sacrificed himself as he did so
yeah you guys think this is a
this is a space pirate just like peter
quill his numbers seemed higher than we
thought
yondu would be even higher and like
every time you use one of those arrows
and both guardians one and guardians two
he has taken out dozens of people it
happened so fast
it's like roadie or in an infinity war
it's just like in the blink of an eye
like scores are dead as a result of this
swift move
and next we've got most popular and wow
this guy everybody smiles when he walks
down the hall this guy really lights up
a room
he's been known to get his grades raised
from failing to passing just with his
charm alone ferris bueller of the bunch
i recall a central parking fall
he is the fairest mueller of this list
that would be our friend loki
with uh what we can credit to him 336
kills
now who knows how many more loki has
because he disguised himself as someone
else like we don't really truly know
what we could tell what our crack
research team of me
and a bottle of code red mountain dew
and 5 am viewings of these movies
we have 336 so let's talk about let's
break that number down we've got four
frost giants in thor that should be 100
people each but it's four
80 people in avengers pre-new york
natasha says
he killed 80 people in two days he's
adopted
74 new york casualties according to
thunderbolt ross
four dark elves in thor dark world and
10 soldiers in ragnarok so
you know add some of those numbers up
okay so that's that's
a good number we also kind of looked at
the fact that he was fighting alongside
thor for a lot of battles right
yes thor casually admits that he killed
3 000
and then based off the number of frost
giants we see loki kill in that battle
based on the number we see thor kill
it's a ratio of 1 to 18.
so applying that to all the past battles
to 3 000 we get about 160 164
from loki's past battles but that's
probably lower
uh than what it really is that's just
what we can average out that's how we
extrapolated to that number
all right moving on next we've got the
uh recipient of the superlative
nicest car and if you remember nice's
car usually went to the rich kid who
wore his collar popped up
kind of strutted around with some
swagger nicest car really usually
equated to
parents who made a 30 000 investment in
their 16 year old kid which is just a
truly insane thing to do
and that the winner of nice's car and
this is going to be ronin the accuser
a personal favorite of mine because i
just think lee pace is a phenomenal
actor with 796 kills
wow uh he killed the other he killed the
nova corps fleet
that was most of them right there right
that was hundreds and hundreds of them
absolutely he was not hesitating uh
countless scrolls
and other cree enemies some people think
that if you really factored in
how many of the nova corps that he
killed it would be 80
000. i mean in the comics there they do
have a massive massive fleet like that i
think
on screen it's it's less than a thousand
and that's what we're doing on screen
we're doing on screen guys
i have always said we're doing on screen
so next this is uh
most frequently skipped class this
person is
absent for the majority of the movie
only to reveal themselves at the end and
that is dormammu
dormammu with a thousand kills dermable
only kills
one character on screen doctor strange
but he kills him countless numbers of
times
12 moves are on screen and in a deleted
clip they say
doctor strange saying something like
we've been through this 1 000 times
we've got him killing doctor strange
at least a thousand times i guess that
counts he did those were separate kills
for him from his point of view that was
a thousand different
people who look just like doctor strange
who are you people
a thousand doctor strange clones and he
murdered all of them in horrible ways
so i think those each count next we're
gonna say best style that's dressed
and that is just because if i could
dress the way this man dressed
it would be ridiculous i don't think
they make his costume in a 3x tall
so best dressed he's my neighbor in
sherman oaks california
no one other than killmonger michael b
jordan
he bought a mansion for his parents
right down the street from me and it's
hilarious because it's
surrounded by apartment buildings it's a
massive mansion and then just
apartments everywhere so come find him
guys find him take pictures of him as
he's leaving
uh invade his privacy john cut all of
this out so i don't burn my bridges with
michael b
because god if we could be friends i'd
do anything uh killmonger
has 3 000 kills let's see
zuri ulysses claw the museum curator
dora milaje guards and 3 000 previous
enemies
based on the scars on his body so the
makeup artist said there were about 3
000 scars placed on his body which he
identified as you know
he scarred himself every time that's
crazy i mean
i kind of want to reach out to ryan
coogler about this because yes it's
really cool
that would make him by far one of the
deadliest single
killers mercenaries in human history 3
000
like winter soldier we estimate it as
way
less than that 3 000 that's huge
and he's not killing them by dropping
bombs on cities he's like taking it out
one at a time these are difficult kills
these are these are people are suffering
not a good look
so that brings us to we're down to our
top three
three most murderous mcu villains and
first is i gotta say most attractive
that's always a superlative that feels
kind of gross right like you're voting
on a person that you're like all right
we're objectifying this person
completely but let's be honest
if you want an award for most attractive
you would forget that
you'd be like you know what normally i
don't think objectifying people is okay
but if you've decided that i'm most
attractive
i accept this award it's also weird
because like you know there's some
yearbook uh faculty advisor who had to
print that
and imagine this idea of like these two
17 year olds right now
i have to type in the words most
attractive and
and sign off on this and it's just gross
yeah it's uncomfortable but we're gonna
plow through
most attractive is hella hello with
three thousand three hundred and eleven
kills again this is what we can deduce
okay from the movies uh let's talk about
who she's killed
the warriors three not to be confused
with the questions three is how you
cross a bridge if there's a troll
asgard's army the velka rior scourge the
executioner
yeah yeah and i think the kind of like
loki we kind of have to imagine because
we did see murals
and there were historical murals that
showed like piles and piles of bodies
so the way we we got to those numbers is
like thor admitted to killing three
thousand
his whole time fighting alongside odin
was essentially what hela said she had
before thor's existence
so we're going to say at least 3 000
kills can be contributed it probably was
way higher
she helped odin conquer most of the
realms so you gotta imagine
she probably fought in even more battles
alongside odin
to take out as many if not more so i
think it's fair to say her numbers are
that high
absolutely okay next is uh kind of our
last superlative before we get to the
obvious
champion of all this as we said before
this person is going to be the recipient
of the ward of the the matthew
mcconaughey
this person is way too old to be in high
school award did you go through puberty
like seven or something in honor of the
kid that you're like
i know that you tell everyone you're 18
but it feels like you might be 35
and like you have no problem getting
beer you somehow have a son
in the same grade as you but anyway that
goes to
ego the human planet with 10 million
10 million kills thousands of partners
thousands of offspring
i implanted thousands of extensions of
myself on a thousand worlds
and based on his skull pile let's just
ballpark that at about ten thousand
right
and then after that like after he
activated all of his plants like
goose goo exploded everywhere who knows
how many killed
and all of his i mean the guy's been
alive for eons yeah so i think that's
fair
so if you have like 10 000 uh uh skulls
in that pile another 10 000 of each of
the sexual partners that he killed so
it's like 20 000
and then like um like millions of people
like on each of those worlds it's ten
thousand different worlds if like
another
thousand people die in each of those
explosions now we're getting up in the
millions we're getting up there for sure
i mean we're gonna any way you slice it
that's the second most prolific killer
but of course most likely to succeed
because we know for a fact for even a
brief time
he does succeed his big daddy thick
thanos
with five trillion kills
with a t sucking down darjeeling
half of the universe trillion with a t
in a snap
half the universe gone how many souls in
the marvel universe
10 trillion according to heimdall in
thor the dark world
from here i could see nine realms of 10
trillion souls
so all right 10 trillion divided by two
those deaths were all reversed
technically but for a time
before hulk snapped them all back but he
still had a lot of people who were dead
as a result of him despite the snapping
reverse that's right because he called
he called the xander
uh he called xander population 12
billion meaning six billion were killed
it's got to be
that he's also he's killed there's a
hobare the asgardian refugees which were
2
000 of them killed and several other
worlds uh he killed vision
he killed loki he killed his daughter
gamora
so i mean this man he's pretty effed up
uh safe to say at least 10 billion
remain dead
as a result of thanos's actions so no
matter how you slice it
this guy i'll tell you what yeah because
you gotta attribute all the people that
he fought
in that in-game final battle who
remained dead uh he fired on his own
troops that was
hundreds maybe thousands there that he
shot yeah he
he killed a bunch of sorcerers i mean
none of our main avengers other than
tony stark
died in that but like if if only one of
them died there's probably a bunch of
like sorcerers and ravagers who who
died there too wow for 10 million like
i'll say tommy even the billion range is
hard for
anyone to fathom how much billion of
something is right
because there's seven billion people on
this planet so imagine like a trillion
that's like that's a thousand billions
it's just one trillion
i'll say something controversial that's
too many people to kill you shouldn't
kill that many people
it's unfathomable literally i'm going on
record saying if you kill a trillion
people
you're not on my good list you're on the
naughty list ho
ho right before that one few of a
trillion
you're on the fence but once you cross
that trillion markers sir
you are not on the christmas card list
anymore you
are cancelled and that's not cancel
culture that's just good common sense
all right thank you for breaking that
down uh tommy i we knew that thanos was
the deadliest but we didn't understand
fully
how he was the deadliest and it's
interesting to learn about people like
hella and ego there too and dormammu
dormammu i
didn't think would really clock in on
that list but he's up there as well and
it'll be interesting to see how
people like galactus or taskmaster top
some of these other villains
yeah i know they're gonna be pretty
deadly too we can always we can always
create a second edition for these lists
we'll come back once we have new content
someday that's right
god please yes oh please all right let's
thank some people
who helped us make this episode first
off thanks to our friends from audible
for sponsoring this episode listen to
the new audible original the sandman
it's based on the best-selling dc
graphic novels written by neil gaiman
which were hailed by the los angeles
times magazine as
the greatest epic in history of comic
books and i i could agree i could agree
with that
this audio adaptation is decades in the
making and stars professor x himself
james mcavoy in the title role
follow morpheus the dream lord as he's
pulled from the dream realm and
imprisoned on earth
when he finally escapes he must restore
his power to rebuild his dominion and
that is just the start of it
featuring a powerhouse ensemble cast
including rizz ahmed kat dinnings
michael sheen
and more in your wildest dreams you have
never heard anything like this
listen now only on audible just go to
audible.com
the sandman i'm in we also want to thank
our friends at hero health for
sponsoring this episode it's hard to
remember to take medication
like when i wake up in a cold sweat
thinking about old cat room in the
streets dancing with old ladies the last
thing on my mind
is taking my pills right hero is your
medicine cabinet reinvented
the hero pill dispenser sorts all daily
medications and delivers them all with a
push of a button
if medication isn't taken the hero app
will send a notification to you
or a family member or a caregiver so a
dose is never missed hero it makes
it simple and easy to make sure you or
your loved ones stay
on track and get the right meds at the
right time every time
your hero membership includes the app
the pill dispenser and 24 7 support for
just a dollar
a day hero even has an optional service
that delivers medication directly to
your door
never miss a dose again and always have
peace of mind with hero right now if you
go to herohealth.com
big question you'll get 50 off the
initiation fee
and a 30-day risk-free trial with a
money-back guarantee
that's herohealth.com big question to
start your membership with 50
off in a 30-day free trial don't forget
that's herohealth.com slash big question
and uh now we're going to move on to
some bite-sized questions that i'm gonna
try to answer
so hit me with those questions you got
it eric here we go
coming at you civilian on discord asks
oh yeah
civilian who is the youngest super
villain
ooh um okay well that's an interesting
question right because super villains
tend not to be kids and i think the
reason for that
is just that like children are kind of
stupid like they don't
have the life experience or really the
emotional capacity
let alone the power like the physical
strength to
really make a compelling true villain
now of course there are exceptions to
this like you know if you saw that movie
bright burn
or looper is a really good movie horror
movies like the omen there's plenty of
evil kids in the history of
uh media it's more common to see
dangerous super kids that are just
misunderstood rather than evil
and the reason for this is that think
about it if you're
the teller of a superhero mythology tale
it's
pretty reckless and dangerous to suggest
that kids innately could be born evil
like you don't want a kid flipping
through a comic book and being like
oh here's a villain kid what if that's
me and then he does horrible things
because he wants to embody that it's
better to have like superpowered kids
who are maybe misunderstood or
accidentally dangerous but then they
find
you know goodness in themselves yeah
like nemo from finding nemo
that that little um lucky finn was a
killer he used it like the way uh
buffalo bill used uh his arm in a sling
to trick women to help
[Music]
oh [ __ ] but uh there there are a couple
uh exceptions that i think we should
talk about and uh batman beyond return
to the joker remember there was that
brainwashed joker junior
it was kind of evil for a second but
really he was just like brainwashed and
there there have been
actually old super villains that are
just trapped in the bodies of children
but i did find an answer to this there
is a child
super villain that has been under our
noses the whole time the whole time
the whole time in the mcu ultron
ultron was only a few days old that
movie
didn't span over a long period of time
and it's not just like the logic of this
robot
is is young james spader specifically
made a point of making
ultron youthful immature kind of like a
teenager that was an acting choice a
character choice for the character he
wanted to be like a teenager know it all
who like snaps whenever he's corrected
or compared to daddy like there are
moments in the movie where he acts like
a kid he goes like leave me alone
leave me alone and then he like when he
cuts off claw's arm he's like oh no no
no no
i'm sorry i'm sorry someone will fix it
right like he's
he's childlike so ultron is your kids
super villain
ah very good question number two lil jay
mills on discord asks
what did hulk and tony see in the soul
world why didn't we see this
oh actually you know we do have an
answer on this from the deleted scenes
in the interviews there was a deleted
scene that showed tony stark's soul
world moment after he snapped in in-game
where he would have met with an older
version of his daughter morgan played by
catherine lankford
and she would have said oh it's okay to
move on she's gonna grow up okay look
i'm already like a young adult now
and it was cut because this would have
been the first time we saw
morgan in this form played by this
actress and audiences had no emotional
connection
to that face so they cut it also it
would have slowed down the movie like
this would have been
in between the snap and all of thanos
forces dusting away and i think and then
we needed to see all the remaining
troops and thanos himself dusting away
we couldn't prolong with a couple
minutes of this weird reflective moment
it's uh later in like recent re-watches
the screenwriters and directors did
point out that
there was a hulk soul world moment as
well that was never shot
uh they revealed that they drafted a
dialogue between
bruce banner's identity and the hulk
identity kind of like the the two halves
talking to each other in that orange
realm they also said there was another
idea that they would have had hulk
speaking with natasha romanov
but it was never written out and i guess
they didn't want to like contradict
anything that they might do in the black
widow movie
it also wasn't shown in the movie for
similar reasons it was like a pacing
thing they just
needed to see the consequences of hulk
snap we need to see like what happened
when hulk snaps and then everybody come
back for a second
uh we didn't want to slow things down
very good all right well
two two convincing answers you're doing
way better than when i do this
you're much better at this than me eric
all right keep it to marvel or matrix
i got you covered question number three
marvel henry
as opposed to dc henry his evil
archnemesis
asks on the old twitter when thor
summons his hammer does it go in a
straight direction to him possibly
harming anyone in its path
or does it avert harm does it does it
dodge people or
oh um interesting question well i'm
pretty sure
mjolnir almost always travels the
shortest distance which would be a
straight line
it comes back to him directly to him
when it's summoned and we have seen a
few
examples of this in the mcu like uh in
thor ragnarok he he used it to threaten
loki remember when he went look who's
pretending to be odin
he also used it to smash up doctor
strange's sanctum sanctorum as a kind of
like [ __ ] you
because yeah just [ __ ] him around
that whole scene so he just like gets
him back by smash it up and then of
course back in avengers when he was
fighting the hulk on the helicarrier he
summoned it through the walls of the
helicarrier
breaking all kinds of stuff but i think
mjolnir can
move on on a curved path like thor's
definitely hooked that thing a bunch of
times so he killed a bunch of fire
demons and ragnarok
like circling it around and then coming
back to him it's it's not necessarily a
straight line
but either way it would be a conscious
decision by
thor or whoever the wielder is like he
must mentally instruct it
to bend its path around other objects so
if it were coming through weaving
through people that he cared about
i'm sure he could he could control that
but most of the time it's just like
directly to him
and he doesn't really care what's in
between not me i would use it to take
revenge on everyone i'd be like
sorry just my hammer sorry my hammer
knocked you out on its way
i can summon a hammer with my hands so
yeah tommy there's a there's a school
between you
class is dismissed oh my god
it's a college it's a college yeah it's
a college of really old adult learners
who are
all awful people
so don't worry it's the electoral
college yeah
all right we got time for one final box
scraps
question and since it's summer time but
sadly most kids can't go to summer camp
right now
i'm playing [ __ ] in the galaxy of
this
sucks camel dick we thought we'd rub it
in their faces and take this question
what is your most memorable summer camp
experience
oh what you are this is good and this
this
this this was a for me a a wide variety
because i had a couple things to choose
from my own going to camp as a kid and
then my being a camp counselor as a
also still a kid and adult
so i have to say the wildest thing so i
worked at
as a counselor in a camp and it was
really kind of an interesting thing
because
you could become a council i think a lot
of camps are set up this way you become
a counselor like the year
after you aged out as a camper yeah so
there was like a
cit right a counselor in training yeah
absolutely and it was like so there's a
very like weird
gray kind of no-man's land of these kids
that are really probably not old enough
to be
camp counselors but they're still or
are there or they're too old to be to be
campers so we had a talent show
every year and there was a girl who had
aged out of being a camper and became a
camp counselor
she decided that she wanted to do uh
celine dion's
album for her talent show the whole
album
[Music]
she she got she did
like four songs before we had to cut it
down
[Applause]
[Music]
and she was not she she did not think
that this was an issue at all like she
was like
going and she was going hard this was
like this was like
pre tick-tock she was an innovator i
will never forget all of us trying to
figure out how do we tell this kid who's
still a kid
without embarrassing her because she was
like 14 or 13 at the time
you have to stop doing this like even
the little kids were like this is pretty
cringy
that you would do this so in terms of
stories that i can tell legally without
getting sued or
anything i will say that was my most
memorable summer camp experience what do
you got for me
i also worked at a summer camp i believe
i i talked about this in a past uh
episode of big question maybe with you
when i worked at one but so i'll talk
about one that i went to as a kid
so i went to a camp that was for 12 to
14 year olds
and it was hosted by uh the catholic
diocese in jacksonville florida
and it was called camp risk and i think
the idea the name was
like as you become a teenager it's like
a risk to reconcile your faith with
societal
uh pressures
which makes sense it was it was mostly a
typical summer camp it was a blast it
was super fun
you know we would do like swimming
ultimate frisbee we had a talent show
we would do like water balloon hunts
there was a dance but you know because
it was hosted by the diocese we had like
morning and evening prayers and
there was a mandatory abstinence
workshop let me explain
which i i think was what the camp was
all about i'll be honest not necessary
for me it was already mandatory without
a workshop
so yeah oh me too me too yeah it still
is i think
yeah absolutely um and what i love about
summer camp stories i'm so glad we got
this question
is there are summer camp stories but
there's also what i love the year two
summer camp stories where you go
back to summer camp and then all year
long you're working yourself up thinking
yeah this summer i'm gonna run that [ __ ]
uh yeah
different this year okay this year i'm
gonna here's what i'm gonna do and you
list it out you lie in bed
and my first year there i was like a
total wildflower super shy just taking
it all in so my plan
the next year was to go back and be the
popular guy
and i had a plan i had like a three-step
plan and the first step was
you gotta dominate the dance circle at
the dance yeah oh yeah because
that guy at our summer camp the dance
was tuesday night
so all you have to do is just dominate
that dance or go out there bust some
moves
and then you are set for the week
everyone's gonna be like hey man
[Music]
and there was always one guy and i'm
like next year i'm gonna be that guy so
that was first step uh second step was
i wanted to troll that abstinence
workshop because there's always some
funny guy who's like ah
he's has sex so yeah and then uh the
third step
was uh i'll explain this in a bit it was
to be the camp mystery man
which oh you'll see how that played out
okay so plan one
uh so here's what i try to do i spent
the whole year trying to learn how to
break dance
uh i joined like a couple friends and we
would hang out on friday nights and like
try to do moves and i was always really
bad at them but i was like i learned a
couple moves i'm like i can do this
uh and then i had spent my birthday
money on this awesome quick silver watch
yeah look cool i was like i'm gonna look
fly i'm gonna break dance
and i'm gonna wait for the perfect song
and then at the dance
tuesday night oops i did it again comes
on and you know
you gotta get out there if it's if it's
2003
you gotta go wild so but the whole time
other kids are getting out there they're
doing moves but i can't find the right
moment and i wait and i wait and wait
and then finally we're in the
oops i did again and i'm like oh [ __ ] we
have like 30 seconds left in the song
so i go in and no one really woos for me
you know for everyone else you're like
woo but for me they're kind of like
i uh i try to do my windmill you know
the windmill move
uh yeah but i'm not good at my legs are
slapping on the ground
and i think i i clip a girl's ankle and
she's like ow
um and then i lose my balance i lose
whatever confidence i had and then my
uh watch smacks on the floor and breaks
and i'm just oh my watch
and it's already already falling apart
well
okay so move on to plan two the absence
workshop was thursday afternoons
and uh they had uh an anonymous question
box where you can ask anything any
question
you want and uh there was always one kid
who had the hilarious question i wanted
to be that one
so i i wrote one down i realized no one
else is really writing questions this
year
people in this workshop are kind of
taking it more seriously just listening
and there was this counselor named annie
all the other counselors were cool annie
was the
the one counselor that they just hired
to run this workshop because she was
taking it
dead serious and um so she opens a
question box at the end of it
reads my question which was can i make
babies with a gorilla
oh yeah she frowns and i'm waiting for
people to laugh
and no one laughs because people are
like oh this guy seriously thinks you
can mate with a gorilla and procreate
with a gorilla
and she looks directly at me and i'm
like i thought it was supposed to be
anonymous i didn't write my name on it
but i think she knew it was me
yeah and she just kind of says i asked
you all to take this seriously
so already i'm like oh that didn't
really work
so plan three be the mystery man was a
weird one
um so a bit of background the first year
there was this one kid who was a cool
guy and he would leave these little
mystery love notes from one color team
doing so everyone would split up in
different
colors you know and he would eat meals
with the the purple team and
you would have all these like trinkets
and toys and purple stuff on your table
to like show your team pride
and uh but he would leave these little
love notes from one color team to
another one
and uh just for fun and it would be like
oh
uh blue team i'm in love with you let's
run away together signed
the silver team and everyone love these
notes and look for them
look forward to them every meal and then
at the end in the closing ceremonies he
revealed himself and it was like whoa
and like it cheered for him and then i
was sitting there i'm like i'm gonna be
that guy next year i'm gonna do it
because he was aging out
but tommy i um i went too far
oh no i love notes so my notes
were like creepy stalker letters
there were like threats of violence it
would be like
dear red team how red will your blood be
when i'm done with you
always watching the yellow team and
everyone's just like
oh what are these uh i escalated it
i um kidnapped a stuffed kermit from the
green team table
and i left a ransom note with a polaroid
i had taken of kermit on the camp
bonfire saying like you have 18 hours or
something
it was really [ __ ] up and it was a
very big deal
people were scared the camp director had
to make a statement
at lunch that day like um whoever's
doing this
please stop and i've got freaked out now
there was this one guy who was the cool
guy he was like the summer hunk that
year he's this devout
christian nice dude named tim and
he saw he saw my polaroid camera in my
foot locker
because who has a polaroid camera i just
had a polaroid camera is the only kid
out of polaroid so he figured it out
from that
and i was like tim please don't tell
anyone and he's like um
i won't but you gotta stop you gotta
give kermit back
um so i um tail between my legs returned
kermit
and i never admitted to it i never came
forward it was just kind of this like
creepy zodiac mystery that no one except
him
ever
[Music]
and like defeat no one likes me and i'm
sitting by myself and
one thing i have is just my cracked
quick silver watch and now that the
services are cracked i can kind of use
it to like glare a couple people at once
like glare sunlight in people's eyes
from across the campground just
with people and i just wasn't even
thinking about it and then i'm sitting
there and tim is across the way
and i shined it in his eye and he's like
surrounded by girls
and i and i shine it right in his eye
and he's like oh he looks over and sees
it's me
and he i can see him sigh to the other
people around him he goes and i never
heard him cuss
but here he said i hate that guy
oh no oh my god
and they're all like tim tim timmy's
like no he's just i don't want to go
into it but that guy
sucks he's such an [ __ ] and that that
was me
you became like the super villain of
that camp you were the youngest super
villain in the mcu
it was was quick silver watch the watch
escalated i would have been like a jason
voorhees of uh
camp but but an abstinent jason voorhees
which is important
just don't try to be cool let it happen
yeah if you're
meant to be cool you'll become cool if
you're not you'll you'll learn how to
play
dungeons and dragons and uh instead of
catan
and and host new rockstars videos
well that is our show tommy it's been so
great to chat with you
thank you for breaking down the
deadliest mcu villains a reminder that
all of you can join our official discord
by becoming a patron at
patreon.comrockstars
you can also get an audio version of the
show by subscribing to new rockstars big
question wherever we get your podcast
you can send us your big questions on
twitter using the hashtag bigquestion
or of course uh join our official
discord server we'll more likely see
your questions there follow me navas
follow new rockstars that tommy bechtold
follow new rockstars on social subscribe
here on youtube get too much information
on all this stuff you care about
thanks for joining see you next time
tommy bye
person woman man camera television got
it
still got it all these years later all
these years
these years i've taken their oh my god
dude that
camp story